2007 an amateur archeologist searches
through online satellite imagery looking
for ancient sites he spots something
strange a three armed shape in the
middle of a barren desert landscape
searching online and finding this what a
fantastic find the satellite image was
captured over the deserts of the Kazakh
steppe in northern Kazakhstan it's not
something you see in nature why would
anybody do that what were they trying to
say the massive geoglyphs in the Kazakh
desert are so remarkable they attract
the interest of NASA scientists they use
satellite imagery of the area to conduct
a remote investigation NASA of course is
very excited by this to see their
equipment being used not just for
discovery in space but also here on
earth satellite photographs revealed
that the three arms shape is not the
only large symbol in the area hundreds
of weird geoglyphs are spotted strewn
across the desert landscape some
featuring crosses dots rings and lines
they're beautiful they're massive and
they show off the ability of mankind to
do things that are impactful from
distances as far away as space
archeologists investigate at ground
level and discover the patterns are made
up of mounds of Earth the evidence seems
to indicate the geoglyphs are far older
than anyone previously imagined
so one culture that could have created
ease features was the Manhattan culture
which was around 7500 BC to 500 BC the
mysterious Stone Age Mahan's a culture
dates from a time before written history
began almost nothing is known about them
in 2015 an investigation of the site
using cutting-edge technology discovers
that it might not be Stone Age at all
archaeologists use a technique called
optically stimulated luminescence or OSL
and date one earth work back to just 800
BC far more recent than first thought
Oh a cell dating is a kind of
methodology where sand would have been
exposed at one point the Sun so it tells
us one's last time that sand saw lights
giving us an indication when humans were
building this feature 800 BC is close to
the dawn of the Iron Age a time when
monumental structures start to appear
elsewhere on the Russian steppe
[Music]
that certainly does suggest it's more
likely to be a kind of ceremonial
structure because it's a very odd shape
the scale of these vast earthworks is
what kept them undiscovered for
thousands of years they are only visible
from above who created them and who they
were created for remains a mystery